اذا كانت ايران مستعده للامتثال
الالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاق 2015 فنحن على
استعداد لفعل شيء نفسه اذا اضطرت اسرائيل
الى الاختيار بين الاحتكاك مع صديقتنا
الولايات المتحده وبين ازاله التهديد
الوجودي الايراني فان ازاله التهديد
الوجودي او لا
[موسيقى]
امكانيه توصل اتفاق ولو جزئي بين ايران
وبين ما يتعلق بالملف النووي الايراني
خاصه في ظل حديث مؤخرا حول قيام ايران
بتخفيف او تقليل سرعه ما يتعلق بتقسيم
وهناك حاله
متواصله بما يتعلق بالتواصل الاتفاق بين
طرفين محاوله تعطيل او تخريب اي اتفاق هو
يعتبر هدف اسرائيل مهمه
[موسيقى]
هنالك ثلاثه ملفات هي تريدها يمكن القول
بكل ثمن الملف الاول بكل ما يخص
الجبهه الشماليه والحدود اللبنانيه الملف
الثاني السعوديه بدون ادنى شك وكذلك
الاستيطان
[موسيقى]
البيت الابيض سيحاول ان يركز على انه
الرئيس اذا لم يكن على وفاق مع
نتجاهل لكنه سوف يستمر بدعمه القوي لدوله
اسرائيل ولحقها في الوجود
حبي لاسرائيل عميق منذ زمن طويل وكما قلت
دوما لو لم تكن اسرائيل قائمه اليوم لكان
يجب انشاؤها